before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
well
here we go again
[Music]
the timeless
children
oh boy here's the funny thing
my memory of this
was that it's wrap up for its primary
story wasn't that bad it was actually
kind of okay
but all the stuff that went on with the
doctor and the Matrix and the reveal was
bad
the rest of it isn't really okay
there's stuff there that could have
worked
I think what might have happened first
time I watched it was that
all all my focus of everything wrong
with it just funneled into the Timeless
child concept and I just kind of gave
most of the rest of it a pass and it's
not great again it's not all right I
personally am of the opinion that the
Timeless child is a garbage idea that
should just never have been done
I'll go into a little bit of why some of
this is reiterative of stuff I've done
before but I'll try and give you the
short version of my issues because
they're not necessarily the same as
everybody else's but before I do that
even if we take that and set it aside I
don't think the rest of the narrative
was necessarily something you just throw
out and don't bother using
you know dealing with a shot wrapping up
the conflict with the Cybermen even to a
certain extent maybe even the stuff on
Gallifrey minus the Matrix stuff could
have been made to work
it doesn't because a lot of it just
doesn't get a proper payoff it gets
ignored or it gets rushed through
like the master randomly deciding oh
I'll just kill a shot
because if Assad's around well he's
something you have to deal with he's a
storyline you have to properly resolve
but if you just have the master kill him
oh we don't have to deal with that
anymore great
but okay conceptually here's my problem
with the Timeless child
I hate the idea of the doctor being that
important I've talked in multiple videos
elsewhere that my preferred version of
the doctor is as the 12th doctor himself
put it an idiot
with a box and a screwdriver
passing through
helping out
learning the doctor
should not matter
and I don't mean like to anybody
obviously the doctor matters to you know
the people that they save on their
enemies or what have you but the
universe
the doctor should be a blip
at most and don't tell me that well you
know the doctor travels all throughout
time and space and with traveling
through all of that you know they're
gonna build a reputation they're going
to be known they're going to be seen as
important no
all of time and space the doctor is
several thousand years old that is not
even a flick of an eyelash to all of
time and space I don't care how much of
it you spread it across
so just on premise I don't like the
doctor being that important
it makes them less interesting to me
when the doctor is just the most amazing
special thing ever this is part of what
drove me crazy during Crazy during
moffett's era a little bit during Davies
as well but it got worse under Moffett
and I like Moffitt did some of my
favorite stuff but like that stuff drove
me crazy especially with Smith
this is that
writ large
so now not only
is she this super amazing special thing
that we don't even know what she is she
comes from this other dimension we don't
even know where we don't know how we
don't know what she is so now she's
suddenly truly unique and not in the way
that the doctors made you lean
previously being the last of the time
was That's Unique as a Survivor now it's
just like totally unique nothing else
like her so far as We Know
and she is now responsible for why the
time alerts can even regenerate
and we established that regeneration
came before time travel and so arguably
one was built on the back of the other
maybe not technologically but
philosophically if you can continue to
regenerate your life uh you know up to
12 times with the set limit then
um you you have the way more time to
figure out crap like time travel and
make more of an impact and control more
like the time Lords do
so now one of the two things that define
Time Lord society as a whole those two
things being regeneration and time
travel the doctor is solely responsible
for
I mean not creating it technically
technion has more response to that which
is another thing that doesn't work like
they try and build up the the whole idea
of tech taeyoon and like it was it was
your mother she doesn't know who she is
all of this is words like look I never
believed it was the case but I
understand
why a lot of people coming out of this
were prone to think that the master was
just lying
because not only did they most of them
not like what was in here but like
there's literally nothing but what he
presents and most of it's with his voice
over so it's literally him telling her
what this means this was your mother we
don't know her she doesn't know her
this has no meaning no substance nothing
but
here's the thing
it was badly handled and again kind of
like some of the stuff I brought up last
episode of just failing to even give us
throwaway lines to acknowledge that you
understand that something doesn't make
sense but just to acknowledge that you
know okay but yeah we're not dealing
with that right now sort of way you know
I don't have a inherent this can never
work notion to the idea that the doctor
had other incarnations before Hartnell I
don't like it and I think it's deeply
unnecessary on basically every level of
Storytelling
but that's not what I hate
what I hate is that the doctor is now
effectively the most important being in
the universe
I hate that
the Timeless child Concept in and of
itself like the time Lords stealing this
ability and grafting onto themselves I
buy that
I buy that
if it was literally anyone anyone
other than the doctor
I for one would not care nearly as much
again I probably still wouldn't like it
it's executed badly and even coming back
to the pre-harden over generation things
which
at this point everything we have
indicates that The Fugitive doctor Joe
Martin is pre-hardinal and like memory
got wiped but like if she's pretty hard
no why the hell does the Tardis look
like a police box the reason it's a
police box
is because
the Hartnell Doctor Who we know is the
first doctor landed in the 60s in London
and he got stuck
why would any Incarnation prior to that
habit and like I don't actually care
about the answer that much but again the
fact that there wasn't even a
conciliatory line acknowledging that you
know that doesn't at least if Whitaker's
doctor had been like wait a minute why
is your thing a police box even if we
didn't get an answer at least
acknowledging that like this doesn't
make sense so to acknowledge from the
writer to the audience that yes I know
but that's not what we're going to spend
time on that at least would have meant
that it wasn't a mistake
but you didn't and so it all looks like
it's a mistake
it looks sloppy instead of just picking
and choosing what you're gonna cover
it makes it look like you threw in the
police box for the iconography and
didn't stop in there for about two
seconds what that meant and then you
just didn't even bother to cover the
fact that it could have possibly meant
anything at all
the thoughtlessness with which this
concept is applied it's a concept I
don't love and I especially don't love
the detail that it's the doctor but even
even if I could roll with that it is
applied so
carelessly and sloppily
we literally have the master take the
doctor
shove her into an exposition machine
where she does not participate in the
friggin plot for most of the thing to
just get Exposition dumped down on her
this is the clunkiest
way to deliver this kind of thing is to
literally remove somebody from the plot
so they can get the exposition
and by association the audience can get
it too
this is so
poorly handled
I don't think it was a good idea at all
but it's also a it's also a bad idea
poorly executed
because sometimes sometimes
you get something that's a bad idea but
you know what they did it about as well
as it was going to be done I'm
struggling to think of an example of the
top of my head but some actually you
know what is a weird one to go with but
I'll go with it Zack Snyder cut of
Justice League
I'm sick
of Dark Tower super serious
um mythological kind of approach to
superheroes just Zack Snyder's
approaches superheroes I didn't like it
really at any point but after I watched
that movie I basically went okay
I would still kind of make an argument
that this doesn't really need to exist
but if it's going to
that's about as good an execution as it
was gonna get
so if you're not like me and you do
think it's something that is worth
having around then you know you're
probably quite happy but even me who's
you know like I don't know if we need
this we'll still acknowledge it's a Well
Done version of that
this isn't even that
it is sloppily deliberate it is a
convoluted idea that especially now at
this point we know ads nothing
not only nothing to the doctor in terms
of you know her characterization moving
forward we don't even build on this
narratively within this run
and and I've said it before I'll say it
again I do not want Davies I don't want
RTD to touch this I don't want him to
try and fix it I don't want him to wreck
conic ignore it and move on treat it the
way that we have treated the doctor
being confirmed as half human in the
Doctor Who TV movie pretend it never
happened don't give it oxygen and yes I
know that conceptually this idea of
making the doctor super important to the
origins of Doctor Who is not even an
idea unique to chibnol there was the
so-called cartmel master plan for back
in the 80s where it was going to be
revealed that the doctor specifically uh
going with the Seventh Doctor but you
know just the doctor in general was Far
older than he had ever let on and was
actually one of the people who first
helped the time Lords
um create time travel in the first place
and it was a stupid idea idea then
we dodged a bullet that that never got
around to happening
apparently it was just a very slow
moving bullet because of variation of it
at least in terms of thematically and at
the core of what it's doing of just
making the doctor super important to the
time Lords
we still got hit with it
so
and the fact that this has to fit into
this episode it takes the legs out from
under the rest of this thing the
Cybermen barely get a proper look in
because we're dealing with all this
other stuff so the Cybermen are just
kind of there they could have been
replaced with literally anything to just
be the generic threat that's there a
shot as I mentioned is casually
discarded great intriguing villain with
a terrific presence well we got to kill
him because we're not going to sink the
time into wrapping up any satisfactory
payoff to his story just have the master
kill him it'll be fine
and that oh the master okay
dewan's performance is fine it's good
even
and I've said before I like his master
and I do but again
the lack of even conciliatory
lines to even hint that answers exist
and that you just aren't dealing with
them for things like
how did he destroy all of Gallifrey
how
this is an entire Society of people like
him he's not super powered
in the realm of time Lords he's more
ruthless
but you can't just say he destroyed the
entire civilization of the planet and
expect us to swallow it freaking how and
again if you don't have the time to sink
into how he actually did it I don't need
a beat for Beat Just acknowledge that he
shouldn't have been able to do it
somewhere so that I know you didn't just
decided to not cover it that you didn't
just it didn't just slip your mind that
it's not another freaking mistake
although actually
coming back to uh the destruction
of Gallifrey actually a couple things
first of all you know what I completely
forgot about that I realized this time
so at the end of Ascension of the
Cybermen the whole idea of the boundary
that crosses over to where Gallifrey is
um
core sharmas the old guy
he'd been sending humans there to escape
the Cybermen
those humans are never brought up
they're never seen they're presumably
dead but even when kosharmus himself
comes over he never asks what happened
to the people I sent here okay so
something that I didn't realize when I
recorded this but I've noticed since in
Ascension of the Cybermen when we first
see Gallifrey on the other side of the
barrier korsharmus does say I've never
seen it look like that before meaning
that where he's been sending them was
not specifically Gallifrey because he's
looking at that and it's something that
it hasn't been before but that does
still beg the question where the hell
was he sending everybody and why is
nobody asking that question why doesn't
he seem to care that he doesn't know
where they went even a token
acknowledgment I just hope that where I
sent people is better than here would
have been enough anyways we're gonna
jump ahead because I kind of lingered on
this point a little and like I said it's
not entirely accurate but the fact that
people were not brought up that's still
a problem for me and then
ah
what was one of the driving issues for
having Gallifrey be saved and this is
this is true of both the meta-narrative
and internally within the show it was
the children
because conceptually when we think about
Gallifrey we think about the time Lords
of the Citadel the big shoulder things
the silly hats we think of the grown-ups
and most of them are bureaucratic scum
but there were children here that was
acknowledged in Day of the Doctor the
fact that the doctor could not bring
himself to let children burn
was why
Day of the Doctor went the way it did
so what this episode does is basically
say oh the problem wasn't that kids were
killed the problem was that it was the
doctor's decision to do it and yes while
that makes it worse and that was a
decent enough reason to undo it
that's not the only reason it wasn't
okay
this show has now established firmly
concretely
children
on Gallifrey
and the master
killed them
we know he did
he killed everyone
that's the entire point of what he has
done
so we have now rendered
the doctor's victory in Day of the
Doctor the entire premise for saving
Gala for saving Gallifrey at all Hollow
and pointless they're all dead including
the children so I will Circle back to
something that I have been noting about
chimnal Zara since his first episode of
showrunner
this era is cruel
it is cruel and it is heartless and
maybe it is that way because of a lack
of consideration but that doesn't make
it better
for me you don't get points for going oh
well we didn't think about all the
children we narratively slaughtered
that just means you are an uncaring
jackass as opposed to a completely
heartless one but at the Act of
narratively Killing all of the people
that the doctor saved is cruel and it's
also unfortunately not up for debate
really because not only does the master
say he killed everybody we don't even
have to take his word for it because
towards the end that freaking death
particle thing which is deeply
unnecessary and added nothing ultimately
but that entire thing which before it
was presented as if it would destroy
like everything like on a universal
scale or at least a galactic one now
it's like it'll destroy all organic
material on a planet like okay well why
was it presented like it was bigger than
that was his plan to just go from planet
to planet to planet and set it off
literally everywhere that's a minor
thing Moving on but regardless that gets
set off
so even if even if in theory you want to
tell me that the master lied about
having killed everyone or that some
people escaped him and were hiding
doesn't matter the Planet Killer bomb
was set off
so they're all dead
what the doctor fought for
the children the doctor fought for are
dead
goth but you know what let's get back to
the freaking Exposition machine again
because I wasn't done with that damn
thing so coming back to the fact that
not only is the Timeless child a bad
idea but it's delivered poorly there are
questions legitimately brought up by the
doctor while she is in that damn thing
that don't even get answered or
acknowledged so like when the master
says that they lied to her and they
wiped her memory she asked the question
[Music]
that is an excellent question
if what they needed from her was
regeneration they got it why would they
keep her around at all what was the
point of wiping her memory because if
she was working for division then
clearly they had convinced her or an
earlier incarnation of her or him or
them or whoever it was to go along with
it but now if they wipe the Doctor's
memory they're gonna have to go through
all that again which clearly they never
got around to doing because the doctor
got a Gallifrey in the freaking Tardis
before that happened why
any of it what was the point of wiping
her memory
is a good question we're not even going
to acknowledge that an answer exists but
it's a good question oh and here's what
this one pissed me off so the doctor
says about the entire I actually kind of
mentioned this in the Ascension of the
Cybermen review uh the master brings up
the fact that the whole Brendan Ireland
thing is like to mask the information
which I brought a blast video and put a
visual filter over it so that no one who
watched it would find a remarkable makes
no sense no sense at all because
that's a place on Earth why is there
Earth data in The Matrix that's supposed
to be about Gallifrey and the time Lords
so like that's not gonna hide that makes
no sense makes no sense but beyond that
he says he sent the images and the
memories of Brendan's life into her head
and that was why we were seeing it
inside the man
no he didn't
no he didn't and if he did
then you screwed it up because
nothing
nothing that went on in Ascension of the
Cybermen indicated at any point that the
doctor was seeing experiencing or
remembering any of this this is part of
what I brought up last time about how
bad the flow into those scenes were it
just goes in and out of them they're
just in their willy-nilly but it's never
ever framed like the doctor going ah and
then like cutting in like it's something
that she's remembering she never
acknowledges that she's having this
thing she never like shakes her head
clear or any of it there is nothing
about the framing in the way that any of
that stuff last episode was presented
that made it look like she was also
seeing it so no
mind
the man no you didn't now I'm just going
to kind of rattle off a bunch of other
stuff that annoyed me the siberium is a
dumb concept it's just dumb concept it's
this idea that it's the single
repository of all cyber men knowledge
why would they do that if they're so
machine minded they would have
redundancies they wouldn't have it in
just one place that's stupid that's
tactically inane when the fam goes
through the boundary and shows up on
Gallifrey Yaz goes this is Gallifrey
that has the doctor even said the word
Gallifrey to you people she hasn't shown
it to you how do you know
you know when the doctor has her plan to
how to take out the Cyber time Lords
which I'm not gonna list on the things
of terrible ideas like what the one
thing that's stupid about that is these
were rough banged up Cybermen and these
these these cyber Lords or time Cybermen
or whatever they look all pristine and I
found myself thinking how the hell along
was the doctor in that Majors thing
because it seems like the master should
not have had enough time to get these
things all set up but like that detail
aside again another thing that could
have been covered by a throwaway line
and they just didn't other than that I
don't have a massive problem with that
concept is it silly yes but it's on an
acceptable scale as far as I'm concerned
but when the doctor has her plan to you
know lure in the master and these things
and blow them all up well
she says to him
no one else one last time
Why didn't
well I know why because so the plot can
happen but I mean like
why coming back to the siberium real
quick it feels like it's a little bit of
a rehash of the Cyber controller from
Nightmare and silver it actually kind of
makes me wish that that's what it was
instead out of nowhere coach Charmers is
like I sent the Siberian back in time
but not far enough back so he's the
reason it showed up and the arrowhead
did it Haunting of villa Dear Daddy but
like what is this ad I guess they're
trying to make him important right
before he blows himself up at the very
end the Dune show up in the TARDIS
oh look there are some species there are
some races that could get into the
Tardis the je Dune no and okay another
thing I want to cover real quick because
I remember showing up in the comments a
lot last time
some people have tried to claim to me
that the reason to do the Timeless child
thing is to remove the Regeneration
limit that is deeply unnecessary and if
it's why chipnil did it then that was
stupid because that was already covered
when we did
um the time of the doctor and the doctor
got a whole new regeneration cycle we
didn't even know the cap on that
wrestling himself said he didn't know
how many regenerations they gave him we
could have gone forever already and I
also know some people will make the
claim that it gives some mystery back to
the doctor but it doesn't it honestly
doesn't it gives us more answers about
her because the mystery that it implants
of where did you really come from is
meaningless because she doesn't know the
extent to which the doctors remain
mysterious is because we didn't know
things about them we didn't know things
that they had done and been through and
now it's we don't know things that they
also don't know that's freaking
pointless that's not mystery that's
packing peanuts I don't even know what
that is okay okay let me
let me take a second here
there are a handful of things
that I genuinely do like
and a lot of them actually kind of
centering around little moments that I
caught with dewan's master so like one
of the things that has kind of irked me
because I didn't remember and it is
actually covered it's one of the few
things actually covered in this damn
thing was why the doctor having the
secret history that again she doesn't
know about it and isn't responsible for
made him so angry that he destroyed the
planet
I couldn't remember what the answer was
and so once it was re-established at the
start of the series that he did destroy
it if I was going what about this pissed
him off so much
well it actually does Factor back into
that aspect of this particular master
that I've noted and think works well
into one's hand which is self-loathing a
little piece of you isn't big
all I am is somehow because of you and
believe me when I say I cannot further
this master but not every Incarnation
Master but this incarnation of the
master yeah I could actually see that
setting him off
I mean he already hates himself but now
he has someone else to blame for part of
why he hates himself he has a tangible
thing he's like well not all this is me
part of this is her the reason it's her
is because of the time Lords I can
punish them
it tracks I do think it actually tracks
for him and there's other interesting
little moments of that self-loathing
for instance when he kills a shot the
death particle is literally inside a
shot and the master almost seems kind of
disappointed that the death particle
doesn't get set off
would have been okay with that and again
just giving you that those glimpses of
self-loathing or towards the end when
the doctor has the death particle and is
threatening to set it off the master is
egging her on to do it
but the instant co-sharmus shows up and
he says he's going to be the one to set
off
the master
does have self-loathing and maybe even a
little bit of a death wish
but not at just anybody's hands
the doctor especially knowing the doctor
would have died too
do it do it
somebody else no
absolutely not
I like that
that's an interesting Dynamic for him to
have this internal conflict and I think
he does it really well
however coming back to co-sharma setting
off the death particle
um just to point out another little bit
of the moral failings of this thing so
the whole thing with the doctor setting
up the death particle and threatening to
set it off and it would wipe out the
master all of the Cyber entities on the
planet including these revised Time Lord
enhanced ones and the doctor herself and
it is framed very much as a parallel or
an echo even of the scene from parting
of the ways
where the doctor has this whole Delta
wave thing set up and he could destroy
the Daleks but it would also destroy
half the life on planet Earth it comes
down to it he won't do it
he won't do it because it's wrong
he's given the option
coward or killer
coward
any day
this doctor seemingly also can't do it
presumably because it's wrong
like that has to be it because there's
no innocent people at stake
the way that there were for Eccleston so
it has to be that she can't do it
because it's wrong
but then the framing of the episode is
oh it's only wrong for her to do it
because we're gonna give it to this old
guy instead it's totally okay if he does
it why
and again you can actually make that
work in some way as long as you
acknowledge that that's what you're
doing
but it doesn't
it seems to understand that it wouldn't
be okay for the doctor to set off this
thing of mass destruction
but it doesn't have enough of a moral
compass to realize that means that
nobody should be doing it in a way that
makes it seem like a win in a Triumph
but it does it
anyway
I think that was everything I had
you know what when this first aired
I think I actually said it wasn't as bad
as hell bent
I think maybe part of that was I had
seen rumors of what this was doing and
while I didn't like it at all I think
knowing at least the possibility of what
was coming might have softened the blow
initially
but on balance no it's not better than
hell bent
hell-bent is at least so baffling that
it's kind of fascinating to try and
understand like it's a mess it's a
disaster
and I do hate it
but
there is stuff to talk about Beyond just
anger
this
what little is good here is incidental
to what most of the episode is
the core conflict with the Cybermen is
disregarded treated as secondary to an
info dump that is badly handled and it's
an info dump for a bad concept at least
to me if you find the concept
interesting that's great I cannot stand
it
and it's not it's not even because oh
it's disrespecting to the Legacy oh they
they want to make her the ultimate Mary
said like it's not any of that it's I
hate it because it's pointless and it
makes the doctor important which just
bores me
so
yeah I do think it's worse than hell
bent
not by a massive margin at least Again
by my standards I know there are some
hell bent Defenders as well out there
we've had our clashes but while I can
find bits and pieces of things that I
like in here they are scant moments I
can find
scenes full scenes at least in hell bent
that are good
that's more than I can say for this
so yeah
I like series 12 overall I I definitely
think it's better than series 11.
I think I like series 12. I've told
myself I like series 12. I'm gonna have
to really carefully look over
this stuff again I do still think series
12 is the best of the chiminal era
but
boy
the Timeless children
have you rewatched this what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon so it pays
the bills for my therapy amongst other
things any money you can give helps with
that you get perks Early Access to
videos like this one and other things
besides uh patreon exclusive Discord
like there's all sorts of stuff check it
out also links for that and also other
stuff that I do down in the description
like share subscribe also help me out
you know
the YouTube things
I don't know why I did that I think I
fried my brain ranting about this what I
really want you to remember though is
that you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore Zuma
fulla to rock the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
Nobby LAX the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support and if you want
to get your name in the credits check
out the rewards on the patreon
[Music]
foreign